the white house is again blasting
republican governors who are
transporting asylum seekers to
democratic-led cities
florida governor ron desantis has
promised to exhaust a 12 million dollar
state-funded program to bring more
migrants to other states this comes just
days after desantis sent two planes
carrying nearly 50 migrants to martha's
vineyard massachusetts they were moved
to a temporary shelter at joint base
cape cod and elaine quijano is there
with more elaine good morning
good morning to you jeff well one of the
lawyers who accompanied the migrants
from martha's vineyard told us that some
of them were reluctant to leave the
island after what they experienced
during that initial trip to
massachusetts for these migrants coming
here to a u.s military base represents
yet another step on an uncertain journey
it was an emotional send-off from
volunteers as 48 migrants who landed on
martha's vineyard wednesday left a
church shelter hola
in my heart
the asylum seekers voluntarily continued
their trek off the island by ferry where
we met 28 year old eliezer perche who
came from venezuela with his parents
says he's hoping to find some work and a
better life for his family
they'll temporarily live dormitory style
at a military base on cape cod which has
been set up as an emergency shelter all
organized by massachusetts republican
governor charlie baker
president biden criticized the
republican governors of florida texas
and arizona who've sent nearly 12 000
migrants to democratic strongholds in
the past five months instead of working
with us on solutions republicans are
playing politics with human beings using
them as props
what they're doing is simply wrong it's
unamerican it's reckless
florida republican governor ron desantis
who organized the migrant flights from
texas to martha's vineyard using a 12
million dollar fund defended his actions
they already bust them out they're gone
they said they said we want everyone no
one's illegal and they're gone within 48
hours
here on cape cod it's not clear just how
long the migrants will stay on this
military base massachusetts state
agencies are working with non-profit
groups to ensure the migrants have
access to a wide variety of services
including legal assistance and health
care dana
all right elaine thank you